roughly 1,500 or so companies at large
died in 2023 this equals the largest
death toll for startups since the do com
crash of 2001 the industry's been
inherently cyclical the entire time I've
been in it and I've been through two or
three of these waves one of the reasons
they're so damn powerful is you
typically take risk on very slowly and
then risk off seems to happen overnight
but the other thing that happens is
valuations expand and so you get this
massive multiple as more risk is being
taken and simultaneously investors and
Founders are being less conservative
they're being less thoughtful about
margins and profitability and all that's
being reinforced by the market so many
of the large startups had accumulated so
much Capital that the effects of the
wave crashing are delayed rather than
immediate the deaths weren't a year ago
they're starting to happen now I would
expect 2024 to be just as bad as 2023